the spine consists of a series of
interconnected Bones called vertebrae
extending from the base of the skull to
the tailbone
each vertebrae connects with the one
above and below at the facet joints
allowing them to move relative to one
another in between each bony vertebra
lies the shock absorbing intervertebral
discs the facet joints and
intervertebral discs work together to
permit the bending and twisting motions
of the back and neck protected within
the vertebral column is the spinal cord
which connects the brain to the rest of
the body spinal nerves emanate from the
spinal cord at regular intervals the
main sections of the spine are the
cervical thoracic and lumbar regions
problems that may occur in the lumbar
spine include the following conditions
disc degeneration or spondylosis a
degenerative arthritis condition that
may cause loss of normal spinal
structure and function spondylolisthesis
a condition where one vertebra slips
forward relative to the one next to it
osteoarthritis of the facet joints a
spinal deformity such as scoliosis
or a fractured vertebra
a doctor may recommend a posterior
lumbar spinal fusion to make the spine
more stable and decrease pain due to a
condition injury or abnormal curve to
begin the surgeon will make an incision
over the lumbar spine
the outer surfaces of the bones will be
removed to prepare for fusion the
surgeon will place screws into the
vertebrae rods will be placed alongside
the vertebrae and attached to the screws
the surgeon may remove small pieces of
bone from the pelvis to use as bone
grafts
other times the surgeon may choose to
use donor bone from a bone bank for
grafting the surgeon will place the bone
grafts along the spine to allow the
vertebrae to grow together and keep the
spine stable at the end of the procedure
the skin incision will be closed with
stitches